so i want to invite you guys
into contemplation i want to invite you
into the endless summer i want to invite
you
into the golden hour veneer
i went to god just to see
and i was looking at me i want to invite
you
it's a transitory enchanted moments
in which you hold your breath compelled
into aesthetic contemplations you barely
understand
face to face with something couldn't
measure
it to your capacity for
wonder you see these transitory
enchanted moments
they heal our fractures they mend our
brokenness they
jolt us into awakening
they shake us to the core
they make us open our eyes
they cast away our sins and cleanse us
in an act of ecstatic absolution
we are transformed we are reborn
[Music]
we are awakened from the lethargy of
custom in the film
of familiarity and redirected towards
the wonders of existence tom duty said
it best
we recontextualize the self as a
marvelous conduit in a timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and
back again and in these moments
we grasp for language we grasp
for the words to mouth the ineffable to
map the terrain the territory beyond the
maps that
which shall not be named faulkner speaks
of the writer's futile yet noble efforts
to fit the world in a sentence
but we try in spite
of its futility we try we do not go
quietly into that good night we rage
against the dying of the light whereas
once we were blind
now we can see and william blake perhaps
he said it best to see the world
in a grain of sand to see heaven
and a wild flower to hold infinity
in the palms of our hand to hold
eternity
in an hour come with me
we shall see it's a world
of pure imagination
[Music]
the curtain parts and what had never
been seen
is devoured by the eyes
it's distinct abrupt framed
it is already a memory
it's a parting of the seas moment you
are
jolted into aliveness
it's characterized by heightened
qualitative
intensity the mystery beckons
the curtain parts and what had never
been seen
is devoured by the eyes
the search is what anyone would
undertake and walk or percy
if we were not sunk in the everydayness
of our lives
to become aware of the possibility of
the search
is to be on to something and not to be
on to something
is to be in despair and as david foster
wallace wrote the alternative
is unconsciousness the default setting
the rat race the constant gnawing sense
of having had and lost
some infinite thing i do not want to
lose
this infinite thing i will not go
quietly into that good night i will rage
against the dying of the light and maybe
it's an act of utility and maybe
it is beyond our capacity
and all the clocks in the city began to
whirr and chime
let not time deceive you you cannot
conquer time
and headaches and in worries vaguely
life leaks away and time will have its
fancy
tomorrow or today said w.h
auden but he is wrong we don't read and
write poetry because it's cute
we read and write poetry because we are
members of the human race
and the human race is filled with
passion
science engineering business technology
these are noble pursuits
necessary to sustain life but poetry
truth freedom romance
these are the things we stay alive for
these are the things we stay alive
for uh
oh just feel it
just feel it
[Music]
i want that video for myself
wow wow wow wow
[Applause]
you